hi everyone it's joanna here so i hit
the gym three to four times a week and
it's been a while since i last shared my
gym routine with you so in this video
i'll be sharing with you some of my
favorite exercises to target the entire
body there will be a total of four
supersets so we will be working on our
legs our back chest shoulders as well as
our core basically all the major muscles
and this workout is great to increase
your strength to tone up to build lean
muscle mass as well as to burn fat
and it will take you roughly between 45
minutes to 60 minutes to complete all
the exercises so let's get started
[Music]
before you start your training always
remember to perform a quick five to ten
minutes of warm-up okay you can do
dynamic stretches so after you warm up
then start your training so for the
first superset we'll be focusing on your
legs as well as your glutes there will
be two exercises and we want to perform
them back to back without any rest in
between the first exercise will be a
smith machine squat followed by in and
out a jump squat
i'm going to load up my weights
so for the first set you can start off
slightly lighter okay all right
and we want to aim for three to four
sets
so this is a smith machine squat if you
don't have a smith machine you can
always do a barbell squat as well so
remember to point your toes forward
shoulder width apart or slightly wider
than shoulder width apart and let's go
for 15.
breathe in as you go down
and breathe out good
push your butt back
keeping your chest up
last
two reps
and done
okay
straight on to
in and out jump squat
all right i'm also going to grab
a 10 kilo
barbell okay
right let's go so this is the plier
movement to increase fat burn
15 reps
remember to keep your knees off
squat low
and keep breathing
ah
okay
right now
take
a one minute break okay so that is
one full set and we want to repeat at
least two to three more sets
so for the second set if you are feeling
strong and you can push more than 15
reps then you want to add on a little
bit more weights okay
all right
second set
it's heavier so let's aim for 12 to 15
reps okay
so feet placement
let's go
go slow down
push it up
don't rush through the movement
that's three two more
and
straight on to
in and out
jump squat
all right with
or without the barbell
i know
legs
are on fire glutes are burning
you can go slow
but do not stop
that's the kind of burn we want
last one
ah
okay
my heart rate is going crazy
so fat burning
is not just about doing cardio exercises
okay
strength training is also extremely
effective to bring your heart rate up
and also to burn fat
so remember to combine strength training
and also your head workouts
take a short break and we want to do
set number three and the fourth one
so we've worked on our legs as well as
our glutes the second superset we want
to focus on
your back
muscles all right so again there will be
two exercises the first exercise will be
a let pull-down using the cable machine
and the second exercise will be a
reverse grip bent over roll
are we ready
let's go
so choose your suitable weight
hold on to the bar
you know make sure that it's a wide grip
pull it down
remember to keep your chest up
and drive the bar down towards your
chest
squeezing your
lats
release all the way pull
and squeeze
so again control as you release
[Music]
okay
right
straight on to reverse grip barbell row
all right so
grip with your palms facing up remember
to keep your knees bent
lift the barbell straight up okay hinge
from your waist
and
pull it up
so this workout
will work more on the mid back
as well as
your lower back
that's two more
okay
take
a shot
one minute break
second set
if you're feeling strong remember to add
on the weights okay try to add a little
bit of weight in every set and as you
increase the weight then you can reduce
your reps so instead of aiming for 15
reps you can drop it to 12 reps and
eventually eight reps remember that for
strength training it's really important
to increase the weight okay let's go set
number two
check your position
hands
release all the way
and squeeze
squeeze
slow up
and
squeeze
good
last two more
one more
okay
straight into
barbell row if however you feel that the
weights are just right it's not too
light it's not too heavy then don't add
on any more weights okay
up
lock up keep your back flat
so this is going to be the third
superset
where we'll be focusing on our chest as
well as our shoulders the first workout
is going to be an inclined dumbbell
press followed by a push-up with
shoulder press
so
adjust your bench to
a 45 degree angle okay
push both dumbbells straight up
straight above your chest slowly lower
it down
and press it up
so keeping
the dumbbells as stable as possible
and as you push up
use the strength from your chest
driving your elbows out to the side
and down
okay
straight
on to the next exercise push up with
shoulder press
so grab
a lighter pair of dumbbells okay push up
jump in
straight into
shoulder press so
this is a
dynamic movement
it's going to increase
fat burning as well press it straight up
back down
remember to try to go as low as you can
in your push-up
or
you can also get onto your knees
working on your chest and working on
your shoulders
ah
take a shot rest as you can see the
first exercise is always a much more
controlled movement whereas for the
second exercise it's more dynamic to
increase fat burn so this is the kind of
superset we want in order to work on
your strength as well as to burn
calories and we want to aim for at least
three to four sets for each super set
for women usually we tend to focus more
on our upper chest because we want to
make our chest appear fuller right so
let's move on to the second set
grab your dumbbells
making sure that
you push the dumbbells straight up
and spread it out
are we ready 12 to 15 reps
press it straight up
okay making sure that the dumbbells are
directly above your chest
not too low
not too high
look straight
at your dumbbells
and remember
control the movements down
and
up
good
last two
and let's go
straight on to
the next exercise
right
push up
into
shoulder press
i know
this is not an easy workout
let's keep pushing
feel the work on your chest
whew
that's two more
one more
oh my
gosh okay
that is the end of your
third super set okay
two more sets take a short rest and we
have one last superset to go
so we want to end each training session
with some core exercises so the final
superset will be a decline at crunch
with hanging leg raises
use a decline bench in the gym and just
place your
legs right here and remember the
strength should come from your abs not
from your hips or your legs okay so just
keep them relaxed go down
and just crunch up
control down
and up there you go
remember
don't just collapse
down
out
feel the work
on
your upper abs okay
and by now you should feel
extremely tired
last few more
down
one more
right
straight onto hanging leg raises
so let's end your training with this
exercise
hanging leg raises okay
just gently
grip onto the handles
release your legs you can either choose
to crunch
your knees up
feel the work
on your lower abs
or if you're feeling strong keep your
legs straight
lift it
straight
up
again
breathe out
as you drive both legs up
oh my gosh
ah
i can feel my lower abs by upper abs
short break
and we want to complete another
two to three more sets to end today's
training session okay
so that is the end of my strength
training routine i love to do supersets
because you can get more work done in a
short period of time and i've burned
more calories than i would if i were to
do steady pace cardio so remember that
in order to burn fat it is not just
about doing cardio exercises but rather
it's about including strength training
into your routine because it will help
you to boost your metabolism increase
muscle mass which will help you to burn
more calories throughout the day so the
next time you're in the gym be sure to
add this routine into your workout and
let me know how you felt in the comments
below if you haven't yet subscribed to
my youtube channel then don't forget to
hit the subscribe button give this video
a thumbs up and let me know what other
workouts would you like to see more of
and i will see you in my next video all
the best